[smooth jazz playing]
- WASN'T THAT THE TURN
FOR OUR POLLING STATION?
- WHY, NO, YOUNG MAN.
UH, SEE, WE--WE KNOW
A SHORTER ROUTE TO YOUR--
TO OUR DEMOCRATIC
POLLING STATION.
- YOU KNOW HOW US DEMOCRATS
LIKE A SHORTCUT,
LIKE GOVERNMENT SPENDING
TO PROP UP THE ECONOMY.
- THERE'S NOTHING MORE WE LOVE
THAN THOSE FEDERAL PROGRAMS.
- YOU TWO ARE DEMOCRATS,
AREN'T YOU?
- WHAT?
[both laugh]
- OF COURSE WE ARE.
- YOU SEE THE COLOR OF OUR SKIN,
DON'T YOU?
HOW COULD WE
NOT BLINDLY VOTE DEMOCRATIC?
- I MEAN,
THAT WOULD BE RIDICULOUS.
- WHATEVER.
ALL I KNOW IS MY POLLING PLACE
CLOSES IN 15 MINUTES.
- WHY, THAT WOULD BE TERRIBLE.
- AWFUL.
I MEAN, HOW ARE YOU GOING TO
ELECT TAX-AND-SPEND POLITICIANS
IF YOU CAN'T VOTE?
- IT'S HARD ENOUGH TO VOTE
WITH ALL THOSE VOTER I.D. LAWS.
- REPUBLICANS.
- ARGH!
THOSE GOSH-DARN REPUBLICANS.
- I KNOW. I'M JUST LIKE, "GRR!"
- YEAH, TEN AND TWO, DOUGLAS.
- RIGHT.
- YOU KNOW WHAT?
IF THERE WERE ANY REPUBLICANS
HERE, WHOA-HO-HO-OH,
I'D BE PISSED.
I'D BE ROYALLY PISSED.
- ME TOO. ME TOO.
- IN FACT, I WOULD TAKE
THEIR HARD-FOUGHT PRINCIPLES,
AND I'D SHOVE IT
RIGHT UP THEIR KEISTERS.
- OF COURSE YOU WOULD.
- WE SEEM TO BE DRIVING
IN CIRCLES.
- DON'T WORRY.
WE'RE ALMOST THERE.
[tires screech]
- LOOK, IT APPEARS
WE'VE HIT SOMEBODY.
WE SHOULD GET OUT AND HELP HIM.
- OH!
OH, MY LEG!
OH, MY LEG.
- OOPSY DAISY. OOPSY DAISY.
- HERE YOU GO.
- I AM PISSED.
I AM ROYALLY PISSED.
NOW, ALTHOUGH IT WAS ONLY
THIS ONE MAN'S FAULT,
I WILL BE USING
ALL OF YOUR TAX DOLLARS
TO GET HEALTHY,
THANKS TO THE AFFORDABLE
HEALTHCARE ACT.
- I KNOW IT DOESN'T SEEM FAIR,
BUT THAT'S SUPPOSEDLY THE LAW
OF THE LAND NOWADAYS.
- THAT'S WHAT I'VE HEARD.
- YOU DON'T LOOK THAT HURT.
- WHY Y'ALL WEARING
THOSE SAME LEATHER JACKETS
AND THOSE DAD JEANS?
- DISPERSE!
[woman gasps]
- BLACK REPUBLICAN
MOTHER[bleep]!